We're talking today about the
changes in the corporation
and, particularly,
about the role
that CEOs play in leading
American corporations.
We're fortunate to
have John Reed with us.
John is the former chairman
of Citicorp and Citibank,
and then after Citicorp
merged with Travelers,
he was the co-CEO
of the Citigroup.
Then, as an indication of the
level of respect the business
community has for
him, he was asked
to serve as chairman of
the New York Stock Exchange
from 2003 to 2005.
So John, thank you
for joining us.
Maybe, we could start just
by getting your perspective
on what is the role
of the corporation
in the American economy,
and, particularly,
the responsibilities of the CEO.
The role of the corporation in
the US has changed quite a bit,
and I've witnessed
some of this change.
My own personal view is
businesses' responsibility
is to create customers,
satisfy the customer needs,
and do so in a way that produces
decent financial results
on an intermediate to
longer period of time.
And obviously, there
is a social role
for the institution itself.
You typically employ
a lot of people.
You invest in factories
or in office buildings
or what have you, and so you
become a part of the community.
And it's changed today.
This idea of
shareholder value tends
to define the role of the
company in economic terms.
Why do you think the
role of the corporation
has changed over the years?
I first became CEO in '84.
At that time, companies
were pretty well
run by the management.
The CEO was, obviously,
the key decision-maker,
but management was really the
controlling group, if you will.
I would say by maybe
15 years later,
the investors had taken control,
and they have a very different
set of objectives.
And I think what happened
is, first of all,
I think there was an
extended period of time when
stock market didn't
give very good returns.
There was pressure
from investors
to get better performance.
Somebody got the idea that, hey,
maybe we could scare companies
into doing better.
It started out with something
called greenmail, where
somebody would take a
position in a company,
maybe they'd own 5%,
6%, 7% of the company.
Then, they'd go
to the management,
and they'd say, look
guys, you really
have some divisions
that aren't performing.
You guys aren't on
top of your game,
and we want better
performance from you.
And if you don't, we're going
to lead some kind of shareholder
revolt.
Well, this took
hold, and managements
that tried to ignore this
got into trouble, often
were thrown out.
Boards were changed, and
pretty soon the shareholders
were in charge, and what they
said was: look management,
we don't care what
you pay yourself,
we don't care how many jets
you have flying around,
but we want the
value of the stock
to go up in a very nice way
and a very predictable way,
and we want it next quarter.
And by the way, it would be
nice if you would tell us,
in anticipation, what it is
you might be earning next year,
next quarter, so forth and
so on, something I never did.
We never in Citi,
during the time
I was there,
provided forecasts as
to what we were going
to earn the next quarter
or the next year because
they became targets,
which if you were one penny
off, the price of stock
would change.
Certainly, we understand the
focus is more on shareholders
and so on, but thinking about
the role of the corporation
in the broader economy and
society, what do you think
are some of the second and
third order consequences
of this change?
I think the biggest
consequence is
you're getting very short-term.
It's very difficult to spend
a lot of money training people
if you're worried
about next quarter.
You train people because you're
worrying about how they're
going to perform over an
extended period of time
makes that investment
well worthwhile,
but it's very easy
to cut if you're just
trying to hit a number.
And the other thing is
where before maybe you
kept a plant open that
maybe could be moved,
but you've been
in that community
for a long period
of time, you had
a lot of workers who
were loyal to you,
and you were loyal to them.
Those decisions changed,
so all of a sudden you
said: you know what?
We can't afford to keep this
plant even though it's not
really bad, it's just not
as good as it might be.
So it's eroded the relationships
both with community
and with employees.
Suppose we wanted to get a
re-balancing of the corporation
where it begins to address
some of these broader concerns
as well as the concerns
of shareholders.
Any thoughts on a path forward?
I think this is a
question of values.
A CEO can say,
look guys, I'm not
going to maximize returns over
the next two or three quarters,
but I am going to maximize
them over a period of time,
and just begin to
adjust expectations.
I think shareholder
value has a place,
but it is a factor
amongst two or three,
and I think the most important
thing is to expand this time
frame a little bit.
Don't say, hey, I'm
not interested in how
the stocks are going to
perform, but let's say,
I'm more interested in
how it's going to perform
over the next 18 months.
But the CEO is going
to have to give voice
to that, because if
the CEO doesn't change
his or her conversation, it's
going to be very hard for lower
level people within
a company to start
taking a somewhat broader
and longer look at things.
We are in the
business here at MIT
of educating the next generation
of corporate leaders and CEOs.
What role do you
think institutions
like ours should play
in this whole process?
You have to get the
conversation going.
In other words, if people
come in and simply say,
hey, the only thing that
counts is shareholder value,
and they don't think about it,
and they don't talk about it,
and they don't say, well, what
are the implications of that?
Well, then, it's
like going to school
and saying the only thing
that counts is grades.
I'm just going to get my grades.
I think business schools here at
MIT, or other business schools,
need to have the
conversation that says, hey,
there's shareholder value.
This is what it means.
This is what it brings.
Now, what are some
of the other values
that need to be thought about,
and what is the juxtaposition?
Because if you get the
conversation going,
then each manager as he or
she goes out into the world,
will begin to have a more
nuanced understanding of what
it is they're trying
to accomplish,
and they'll begin to
bring some balance.
Well, this is great John.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.